thanks to curiosity stream for
supporting PBS Golden Hour KC mutt Kacey
Musgraves won Album of the Year at the
2019 Grammys for her album Golden Hour
becoming just the fourth country album
to ever take home that award so how did
she achieve this crossover success and
what does it mean for the future of
country music we're going to talk to the
producers of Golden Hour to find out the
way that this album came together with
KC was just so natural between the three
of us Daniel and my co-producer and KC I
didn't have low expectations like no
one's gonna like this but I wasn't like
we were gonna display at the grand
meeting yeah I never thought that over
the past decade country music the genre
of Dolly Parton in the Dixie Chicks has
been dominated by male perspectives in
2015 a radio consultant suggested
country stations shouldn't play too many
females if they want a solid rating
saying the lettuce is Luke Bryan and
Blake Shelton Keith Urban the tomatoes
of our salad are the females the year
before that Maddie and Tay released girl
in the country song they're the mint on
the state of females in country music
[Music]
so how does this genre evolve and sound
contemporary while keeping its identity
some people argue that it means crossing
over into polish and others say it means
doubling down on tradition Kacey
Musgraves shows that this choice is a
false binary by mixing elements of the
past and the future throughout golden
hour in a way argue that a lot of
mainstream country is even more overtly
pop-oriented in mainstream country music
the kind of country music that's played
on the radio you hear much more overtly
pop elements like drum machines and trap
throughout the album Kacey Musgraves
takes old traditional sounds and makes
them sound new by recontextualizing them
you know I think Casey had a real clear
vision that she wanted to mix those
things that she had had on her other
albums with some new sounds to bring
those worlds together she previously
hadn't had a lot of like keyboards on
her records and so interestingly even
just introducing the piano and some of
the synthesizers and she was really
open-minded and free to explore that
stuff even one of the most futuristic
sounding moments in the album has roots
in the past
check out the robotic vocoder at the
beginning of Kacey Musgraves song a
Waterworld
[Music]
now check out country legend Pete Drake
in the 1965 country music film second
fiddle to a steel guitar the vocoder at
the beginning it's actually my voice
which is really weird to hear now like
when you hear it a lot concert or
something and you know it's not unusual
for me to hear like my drums or volcano
or guitar parts that I might have
recorded but it is definitely a
different feeling to hear your voice
through a vocoder
oh what a reference to I think Casey
just had that idea she might have
referred specifically to Daft Punk but I
don't know I think she just kind of
identified the vocoder sound as
something that could sound
extra worldly so while this kind of
effect suggests futurism it's also
distinctly retro in fact here's what
Kacey Musgraves told GQ about oh what a
world it's this trippy perspective this
sound where future meets tradition one
thought I had was what would it sound
like if imaging he made a country album
would it work would it make sense maybe
no instrument or sound is more
associated with country music - pedal
steel guitar in fact and George Harrison
and Bob Dylan wanted to make country
albums we got help from pedal steel
player Pete Drake the talkbox guy
however on Golden Hour the pedal steel
guitar is doing something different it's
used more like a texture similar to how
a post rock band might use a guitar
check out the guitar in this post rock
song by Seger Ross
and here's how Casey uses the pedal
steel sound and space cowboy
so some bands have experimented with the
texture of their instruments to create
post-rock is Casey doing a similar thing
with country to make post country
country music is a big part of her story
in her life and in her heart she really
loves country music we weren't making
rule of saying we have to make sure that
this appeals to country especially
because she's never really been embraced
by country radio that's something you
guys think about on a regular basis the
identity of where you guys are coming
from I think it was more of like her
saying I really do love the emotion of
the past deal I think Casey was like
look we're gonna turn the banjo up and
we're gonna turn the steel up so we're
gonna let people know those things are
in there and I think she kind of wanted
to do that because if you're not mixing
genres in a way it's probably not that
interesting throughout the process Casey
made sure that the experimentation
didn't go too far one one thing that we
always kind of joked about was that
Casey's just really good we called her
the ax man because she was always good
at trimming the fat and I think the ax
man ended up really doing us a great
service because the ax man and gave us a
lot of space in music in a way that that
I think allows people to really lean
into it and listen to it as opposed to
being like oh it's all this music coming
at me so Sean Everett is credited with
dolphin magic can you tell us what
dolphin magic is I don't know if it's
ever been made public on this song happy
and sad there's a transition that goes
into the chorus that is this celestial
kind of harp sound it's lifted from a
particular cartoons I think there's an
image of a dolphin jumping out of the
water as that sound occurs and we just
pulled that there might be another
factor that's playing into the crossover
success of Golden Hour the rise of the
yeehaw agenda starting on the Internet
as memes in 2017 to finding it's viral
moment with yodeling kid Mason Ramsay in
2018
from both Solange and cardi B wearing
cowgirl outfits to Lil nas exes
billboard number one Old Town Road being
a cowboy has suddenly become very cool
this rise of the yeehaw Genda has also
opened the doors for people of all
different backgrounds to participate in
the aesthetic of country-western music
when a fan tweeted this KC responded
with this KC's lyrics open the door even
further the inclusive messages of songs
like her 2013 hit follow your arrow
makes her a perfect ambassador for
country music to a wider audience
[Music]
so the son-in-law for cowboy style may
have helped her customer success or she
could be part of the reason yeehaw
became so popular in the first place
there aren't many artists that have
performed at the Houston Rodeo and
appeared on RuPaul's Drag Race Ellie and
I are going to write a Golden Hour
inspired song do you have any tips for
us overall it's good bit reflective and
so you know just reflect on your life
and get out of your comfort zone a
little bit and see what's out there
acoustic instruments like the acoustic
guitar is pretty much everywhere
there's not a lot of symbols our job is
to do Kacey Musgraves style country I
listen to the album I made notes on most
of the tracks usually the progressions
have four one six three five or one six
three four I wrote she puts a lot of
emphasis on the guitar sound kind of
thing I'm not country music does that in
general it has a lot of guitars now but
how will we how are we gonna I saw I
have an idea so I think we could try at
least pulling off putting in guitar I
own an acoustic guitar okay I can kind
of learn basic chords and just strum you
have a guitar and you're gonna teach
yourself
- you're gonna strum some chords on this
guitar why not
you're just gonna just teach yourself
guitar yeah if you just okay so if you
just play just one chord and just strum
it here and there country here we come
before we share what we came up with
we'd like to thank curiosity stream for
supporting PBS curiosity stream is a
subscription streaming service that
offers documentaries and nonfiction
titles from a variety of filmmakers
including curiosity stream originals for
example they have unraveling the
creative mind that's about how our world
has been shaped by those who have dared
to think differently you can learn more
at curiosity stream calm slash sound
fields okay now here's our golden hour
inspired track
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we need some help with the vocals so
download our track from our SoundCloud
at the link in the description and sing
on it and here's a little advice from
Daniel Tosh you country music collects a
lot of furniture in the song square
other songs talk about feelings like
country music likes a lot of objects
[Music]